[VIDEO GAME MUSIC BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
Google Cloud Speech API
enables easy integration of
Google speech recognition
technologies into
developer applications.
The Speech API allows you to
send audio, and receive a text
transcription from the service.
Using the Google
Cloud Speech API,
you can generate captions from a
video file, an audio recording,
or a live situation.
The Speech API supports both
synchronous and asynchronous
speech-to-text transcription.
Over on Qwiklabs, you'll be
diving into the Google Cloud
Speech API.
In just 15 minutes,
you'll create an API key,
create a Speech API request,
and call the Speech API request.
Like with all of
our Qwiklabs, you'll
have all the resources you
need to work on the lab.
There are many applications
for this technology,
and we'd love to hear
what you're doing with it.
Let us know what you're up
to in the comments below.
As you may already know,
this self-paced lab
is part of the baseline data,
ML and AI quest on Qwiklabs.
Completing all of
the labs in the quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.